this week on Lower decks we got to see a
new type of federation Starship and as a
total tricky geek I love it when that
happens but is this really the
federation's first fully fledged killing
machine
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
now as we know the USS defiant was built
as the federation's really first
attempted a focused warship before then
they were famously a bit Fragile the
Galaxy class in fact was almost like a
flying Hotel it had families aboard it
had Hollow decks it had you know about
80 percent of the ship was for crew it
was not a particularly focused fighting
machine if and one that ever became
necessary now after the Borg and then
most definitely the Dominion War the
focus towards needing a warship became a
little sharper and the federation did
start to develop things like the defiant
and other vessels
but even the defiant had a crew on board
it could do tasks like negotiations it
could have an away team and do science
missions and actually have been down to
a planet and do things like that it was
more than just a warship even though
that was the primary focus
now on Lower decks this week we got to
see a new class of Starship a Texas
class Captain incoming ship more Breen
no it's uh I think it's Darkly
now I actually think this is a very
well-named class of Starship because
there's anything we know about Texans
they love guns and they're uh fighting
people I think is fair to say our young
American friend Harris that does the
live shows with us on a Sunday is a
Texan and when I said it's a Texan class
and it's armed to its teeth he thought
that was very funny
three brain interceptors have absolutely
wiped out the Cerritos with almost no
effort at all I mean I know this
research isn't a fighting machine in
itself but I mean they barely landed a
glove on these three green vessels we
know from the Dominion war that the
Breen are a Warrior Race and actually do
have very capable Starships so when the
USS alado turned up and creamed them I
think it's fair to say it showed that
this vessel is a very capable fighting
machine we then find out it has no crew
on board and it is a fully automated
Starship
have they lost their minds
we know from Star Trek that whenever you
have a machine it will at some point go
crazy and try to kill you it happens
over and over again or the computer will
become sentient and try to kill us which
has happened over and over again
so it seems to me that having a fully
automated Starship like this is a death
wish
but
there are advantages to a fully
automated drone type Starship like this
but
saying that though they are all military
related this is a purely military vessel
it has pretty much no other purpose
because it doesn't have a crew on board
it cannot go to a scientific Mission and
send crew down to investigate something
it cannot adapt to things on a
scientific point of view it could be
used as basically a probe and be sent
just to scan something but if then
something happens and you need crew
there isn't that option so this vessel
is designed to be a warship it's
designed to be maybe an escort so to
defend softer weaker targets against an
enemy it's designed to patrol things
like the neutral zone and again engage
where there are threats even that role
is limited because if there is an
emergency say some sort of accident or
something like that
the ability for this vessel to then
react and support such a problem would
be limited you could maybe use this
vessel to transport very hazardous
materials very valuable hazardous
materials something that you want
defending but you don't necessarily want
people near that's one possibility but
really the primary reason for a Starship
like this is to kick ass and it has
already shown us it's very capable of
that I could completely see like a
sovereign class starship with three or
four of these things fighting in tandem
in an automated attack pattern against
something like the Borg and that these
Texas class Starships would be more
Expendable than the much larger Capital
ships but mentioned in the Borg I'd be
very nervous about these Starships
anywhere near the Borg I could see the
Borg absorbing these vessels into their
technology or taking over these vessels
very very easily I have to hope that
that sort of thing has been considered
and there are loads and loads of
safeguards for one it has to be some
sort of AI that controls the star ship
I'm hoping there are lots not to
safeguards in there to stop that AI from
becoming either sentient or just
deciding to kill everyone
I'm very hoping that there's lots of
safeguards in place to stop the vessel
being hacked or as I say attacked by the
Borg and just completely taken over and
you have to hope that there are other
safeguards in place
but let's be honest this is just setting
up a future Star Trek episode probably
on Lower decks where we see a Texas
class starship go crazy and try and kill
us all it's bound to happen because
that's what always happens in Star Trek
foreign
[Music]
I thought it was stunning I have to
admit I really like lower decks because
I I do consider it a love letter to CNG
which which it just is
um and TNG is still my favorite of all
the Star Trek franchises it's the one I
grew up with so it's my favorite
um I love all the references to the Next
Generation and Picard and all the rest
of those characters that I just adore
um I actually thought this was a really
nicely designed ship it looks great I
think
um as long as they've got those
safeguarding places to stop it from
trying to kill us all then it's a very
it's a brilliant idea and it's actually
a piece of the Federation Fleet that's
been missing
I I like any ship that can kick ass
always good
um but actually this episode in lower
decks I just thought it was a very
clever episode it was it carried on as a
normal or Dex episode for most of it and
then the brain turned up and then this
attack at the end this this scene at the
end that I've been running through the
episode is just it's not just a good
episode of low decks it's just good Star
Trek
um if this had been a normal live action
series we'd all be going crazy at this
but because it's a cartoon it doesn't
maybe have the same importance but it
still Canon everyone says that lower
decks is Canon so the USS Alito and the
Texas class starship are now canon in
Star Trek and that is cool
but guys get in the comments and tell me
what you think first of all I'd love to
know what you actually think about low
decks do you love it or hate it because
it does seem to be the Marmite of Star
Trek if you're American you might not
get that reference but if you're British
you'll know exactly what I'm talking
about
get in the comments someone tell me
exactly what you think also what did you
think about this Starship idea do you
think it is just doomed to fail and it's
almost 100 gonna turn around and try to
kill us all T2 style or do you agree
with me that actually it's a brilliant
fighting machine and as long as they've
thought about all those other instances
where the machines have tried to turn
onto some Star Trek that actually it is
a piece of the fleet that makes complete
sense I'd love to know exactly what you
think if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
as always if you enjoy the content and
you want to support the channel consider
hitting the join button
I'm becoming a fully fledged side
tracker as always please stay safe I'll
see you next time
[Music]